so good evening everyone and welcome
tonight marks a meaningful moment for
the Ruderman Family Foundation as we
shine a spotlight on the importance of
mental health awareness and acceptance
in the entertainment industry
this important event is dedicated to
enhance our call for Action around
destigmatizing mental health and
increasing access to programming and
services for young adults with mental
health issues and diagnosis
for the past seven years the rudiment
Family Foundation has remained steadfast
in our commitment to raising awareness
and eliminating the stigma associated
with mental health
through strategic and impactful
collaborations with key stakeholders
across sectors we have crafted programs
and initiatives that uplift the
well-being of our communities and offer
support for those dealing with mental
health issues
we continue to advocate for policy
change partnering with esteemed
institutions and vital stakeholders to
promote greater access to Services
programming and knowledge about Mental
Health because knowledge is power
our partnership with the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences began
four wonderful years ago leading the
work to promote disability inclusion in
the entertainment industry
since then we have expanded our joint
efforts to empower individuals with
mental health issues through a range of
initiatives
these initiatives Foster fresh
perspectives on Mental Health offer an
inclusive experience for audiences from
all walks of life and aim to change the
culture in the industry
together we have created a change in the
environment where aspiring young
filmmakers regardless of their
background or abilities find their place
in the entertainment industry leading to
a more inclusive and diverse industry
over time
tonight we have the privilege of
learning from an esteemed panel of
individuals who are leading the
conversation on mental health and offer
leading mental health initiatives across
the entertainment industry
we hope that tonight's event will
encourage all of us to think about
mental health in our lives and in our
communities in new ways
spark new ideas and deepen our
commitment to expanding access to Mental
Health Services in the film industry
together we aim to help the industry
integrate the importance of mental
health generate new policies Elevate
discourse and offer tools for aspiring
and current filmmakers actors directors
crew members basically everyone who is
involved in the creative process both in
front and behind the camera
on behalf of the leadership of the
Ruderman Family Foundation I want to
express our gratitude to all of you for
joining this important conversation we
would like to extend our appreciation to
the foundation staff involved in
organizing tonight's event and to the
hard-working Partners we have at the
Academy including
some like Bill Cramer Don Murray Bettina
Fisher Janelle English Kendra Carter and
everyone at the Academy Who Remain
dedicated to this issue it is an
absolute honor to collaborate with all
of you on such a meaningful initiative
thank you
[Laughter]
okay so let's get this conversation
started please join me in welcoming our
moderator for this panel to the stage
madirija is a nationally recognized
clinical social work and public health
professional with experience providing
thought leadership training education
consultation and direct clinical
practice to programs focused on Mental
Health Equity Behavioral Health Systems
strengthening trauma and resiliency
mental health epidemiology and Community
capacity building that is a lot thank
you wow
she is also a practicing psychotherapist
and serves as the vice president of
science equity and integration at ETR
which stands for education training and
research Associates a National
Organization focused on advancing
healthy equity
Health Equity and outcomes for children
families and communities please welcome
to the stage Missouri
[Laughter]
good evening everybody
um as I was graciously introduced my
name is Madhuri I use she her pronouns
and it's my distinct honor to be your
moderator tonight for this incredibly
important panel
uh I want to just say thank you again to
the Ruderman Family Foundation into the
academy for not only inviting me but for
choosing to do an event like this where
I'm often asked to speak and it's rarely
a platform where we can reach so many
different types of people and also an
industry that I think this really will
speak volumes too
we live in unprecedented times nearly
one in five Americans in the last year
reported symptoms of depression
suicide is now the leading cause of
death in people age 28 to 34 and kids
aged 10 to 14.
the covid-19 pandemic resulted in a rise
in demand for mental health services
like we've never seen before
I myself as Janelle graciously said I'm
a practicing clinician I served on the
front lines of covid19's pandemic
response in New York City as the
Director of a mobile Psychiatry unit in
New York at its peak what I can tell you
is that it was the most humbling and
life-defining moment of my career
because it showed me personally just how
much work we have to do to normalize and
destigmatize discussions about Mental
Health
the film industry is it has its own
unique challenges where evidence shows
us that extreme pressure and arduous
work environments as well as sometimes
the thematic and dramatic content
themselves of money Productions can be
risk factors for someone to experience
emotional distress on the job or in
their profession if they can't have
their needs addressed and we are
certainly having this conversation
tonight in recognition and a memoriam of
many in the industry who have sadly lost
their battle with mental illness because
they couldn't reach out for help or
couldn't get it in time
I would not be a responsible clinician
to all of your all of you here presently
but also those who are listening on our
live stream that this conversation may
get intense
if at any point you feel you need to
take a break whether you are watching
this at home to turn your screen off or
put the computer down or if we're here
to you need to take a breather please do
so and take care of yourself know that
this panel here sees you and validates
your experience
so I ask you as an audience to go on a
journey with us as we're going to unpack
how the filmmaking industry can Champion
mental mental wellness and safety in
this industry through the lived
experiences and expertise of this
incredible panel without further Ado
it's my honor to introduce you to each
of our panelists
our first panelist is an Emmy
award-winning film and television
veteran known for his powerful portrayal
of the popular character Sunny Michael
Corinthos Jr on the award-winning series
General Hospital
Maurice Bernard's enduring talent and
commitment extend beyond the screen he
has he Champions mental health awareness
through his own personal Journey
with bipolar disorder and his advocacy
work with esteemed organizations such as
the international bipolar foundation and
the National Alliance for mental illness
please welcome to the stage Maurice
Bernard
[Laughter]
our next panelist is a writer director
musician and mental health advocate he
also is inspired by his own Journey with
bipolar disorder Paul dalio's debut film
touched with fire challenges stigmas and
explores the creative aspects of mental
illness with a critically acclaimed
album and upcoming projects including a
rap musical film he continues to shed
light on mental health and challenge
societal Norms please welcome to the
stage Paul dalio
[Laughter]
our next panelist is a renowned mental
health and addiction consultant speaker
and author with expertise in cultural
responsiveness and Health Equity his
newly published book is garnering praise
for its insights on on creating High
performing equity-centric Healthcare
organizations
Dr Pierre Luigi Mancini's impactful work
has earned him prestigious Awards
including multiple Emmy honors
and he continues to advocate for social
justice and mental health a national
International platforms please welcome
to the stage my good friend Dr Pierre
Luigi Mancini
our next panelist is the founder and CEO
of dive Studios and the mindset app as a
prominent figure in the digital media
landscape Brian Nam has built dive
Studios into a leading platform for
Asian American and Global K-pop
audiences with their podcast and video
series amassing over 750 million views
with the recent introduction of mindset
a self-care app Target targeting gen Z
Brian aims to make a lasting positive
impact by fostering a sense of community
and providing valuable content to
millions of active users please welcome
to the stage Brian Nam
[Music]
next a mental health nurse practitioner
psychotherapist and influential social
media content creator with over 2
million followers through his engaging
videos and content Dr kojo sarfo
promotes mental health awareness using
popular Trends in music to educate
viewers about mental health conditions
and the importance of self-care please
welcome to the stage Dr kojo sarfo
our next panelist is a multi-talented
actress director and producer from her
recent directorial debut in the
independent film parachute to her
notable roles in films like Pitch
Perfect and someone great she has
captivated audiences with her versatile
performances additionally Brittany Snow
is an advocate for mental health
awareness and the founder of September
letters a mental health awareness excuse
me a therapeutic writing experience in
collaboration with the mental health
foundation with a book set to release in
2023 please welcome the stage Brittany
Snow
[Laughter]
and last but certainly not least our
last panelist is an actress singer
filmmaker and advocate for change
recognized for him for her impactful
performances in series like little fires
everywhere and cruel summer and the
comedic science fiction series will
versus the future Lexi Underwood
continues to Captivate audiences with
her versatile Talent additionally she's
the founder of ultimate dreamer
Productions and an avid supporter of
various organizations utilizing her
voice to raise awareness on issues
affecting girls and youth worldwide such
as mental health anxiety hunger and
bullying please welcome to the stage
Lexi Underwood
[Applause]
thank you all so much for being with us
tonight I am excited to get into these
questions that we've curated for you
which include some questions we
solicited ahead of time from our gold
Rising uh audience
um and some of them are specifically for
each of you based on your experience or
your expertise but I do want to say that
if you want to chime in for any of these
just give me a signal and we want this
to be a conversation that hopefully
feels enriching empowering inspiring for
all of us should we get started
so I'm going to start with our subject
matter expert Dr sarfo and Dr Mancini
for audience let's start with you Dr
sarfo can you tell us how mental health
conditions can impact daily life
yeah so um before I start I just want to
thank the academy gold program and the
Reuben uh Family Foundation for having
this here tonight and uh that's a great
question when you think of mental health
conditions they if you some you're
somebody who struggle with any type of
mental health struggle you know that
it'll dominate your life you know and
let's start off with depression that's
the leading uh cause of disability
worldwide and it costs people a lot of
things you know you lose friends you
lose a lot of income you'll lose uh you
know sometimes yourself and uh when you
look at the signs and symptoms of
depression you know a lot of times
people will lose uh energy you know you
won't be as motivated uh you'll feel uh
like you want to isolate and with men
sometimes we'll overwork ourselves we'll
rely on substances um more than usual uh
and even for people who don't have
mental health conditions uh I sometimes
worry for those people because if you
don't fall within a certain you know
category uh it's easy for people to
forget forget about you you know and
things like loneliness since the
pandemic I feel like we're in an
epidemic with loneliness where we don't
have the connections that we used to and
I tell all my friends who live here in
Los Angeles if you have you know one
person who will take you to LAX you know
you're blessed because we're not as
connected as we used to be you know so
just having good friends around uh
because we're in a city where you know
we all came here for a reason and we
want to connect but that connection
isn't as strong as it used to be so uh
anytime you feel sad or you feel
frustrated I think that's a great time
to just check in with yourself uh and
see how you're doing
thank you you brought up something
that's really important for the first
time ever the United States Surgeon
General released a report on social
isolation and and loneliness as a
national epidemic which is wild to think
that we're there Dr Mancini if you could
uh elaborate for us a bit because you're
an expert in understanding inequity and
systems access and what access really
means for folks help us understand what
that means thank you Madre and good
evening everybody thank you for taking
time of your day to be here with us and
those that are watching online
so the part I wanted to answer for that
question which is so important is that
not only if we have a condition but then
what are those barriers that continue to
affect us because if I'm aware I have a
condition and I have nowhere to go it is
suffering in silence it's suffering more
than I have to and you know if you close
your eyes for a second if you're
comfortable with that and and I were to
kind of defined for you when we talk
about physical health we have this whole
process right we know how we're changing
we see our body change we see our
Attitude Change is very concrete but
when we talk about mental Wellness there
is no concrete you know how do you see
your brain get stronger how do you see
your emotions get stronger so if I'm
suffering from a condition but then I
don't have access it makes things even
worse now for me to be able to have
access I have to also um unpack with the
barriers to access so we have inequities
and inequities means how come I can have
a therapist but other folks have to wait
six months to get a therapist how come I
have one in my block and then others
have to go across counties and drive
sometimes multiple hours to find someone
and even though we have telemedicine
today I don't have internet access where
I live right so we have to address those
issues there are Financial barriers if I
find someone then that's another
inequity maybe I don't have the
insurance coverage I don't have the
co-pay I don't have the ability to buy
my medications so what happens when I
don't have access when I don't have
access says I suffer and I suffer in
many ways I suffer physically I don't
sleep well I don't eat well I don't take
care of myself I don't want to get out
of bed I I suffer
um with my friends I don't want to see
people I want to isolate and I have a
hard time even taking care of my
personal hygiene my job suffers I'm not
able to behave at the maximum ability
that I'm able to
so when we look at those things we have
to be able to say the ability to
recognize a condition which is the most
normal thing today we need to normalize
the conversation about having a mental
health condition and there is a
difference between a mental health
condition and a mental illness and we
also have to learn about those but then
I have to be able to have the people
that can help me take me to that other
side because the reality is anybody that
has suffered or is suffering today
you're not alone you have millions and
millions of people that are
successfully living with a mental health
condition or a mental illness because
we're able to get the help that we need
when we need it
[Applause]
some of the things you brought up made
me think about
um you know just how much of a hustle it
is to try and make it in this industry
I've worked with a lot of performers and
issues of insurance and access are
hugely important so I want to come to
our actors on the stage to talk to you
all a little bit about what comes up for
you when you hear our experts outline
how symptoms can affect day-to-day life
and what makes you what makes you want
to be a part of a conversation like this
I think that'd be really meaningful for
our audience so I'll start here Maurice
if you can tell us a little bit about
well you know it's funny that he said
that about therapy during the pandemic
as much as I've been talking about
mental health for over 30 years
but I couldn't get a therapist for four
months
and I was at the point of no return the
way I was feeling
finally got therapy saved my life
so it's you know even now I think
sometimes it is very difficult to get
therapy and it could it could you know
somebody could die in a second
let's go to the other side um Lexi tell
us what's coming to mind for you yeah um
number one for me I'm a big advocate of
therapy just not even as an actor as an
artist just the world in general is very
chaotic and it's important to be able to
have that safe space that you can go to
with a judgment-free Zone to be able to
share but I think for me particularly a
big thing that you know I had to get
over especially as an artist as well was
giving myself like just the permission
to be vulnerable and to be myself and to
operate in spaces like I usually do
around my friends and all the things
that I was scared of and worried about I
think that you know us we're constantly
on sets or in different rooms that may
seem a bit intimidating or scary but I
finally took myself you know gave myself
a moment and realized that I needed to
give myself more grace and I need to
give myself myself the space to be
vulnerable and to make mistakes and when
I'm more kind to myself it definitely
makes a huge difference yeah yeah
kindness and forgiveness or themes I
think we'll talk about a lot today Paul
you've been really public like about
your experience I'd love to hear from
you what it's been like for you in this
industry
um well I had a
um mixed experience with the with the
release of the film because the film for
me was very poignant because I was
trying to do a movie that
kind of showed the gifts of it you know
and showed the beautiful aspects of it
and so I made the whole color scheme
around my biggest bipolar hero uh
vincivenko and um you know I I we
actually did the first interactive
experience as the the people in the
hospital start to see like the you know
the Stars projected on the walls around
him
um and I was I was really hoping that
you know my biggest Hope was to kind of
show things through the eyes of someone
who has it so they don't judge it as
much they might actually see the beauty
in it you know because
um so for me when I when I released the
film uh the poignant moment for me was
that it didn't it didn't make any money
and I couldn't get another movie off the
ground
um but then like 12 mental health
organizations reached out to me you know
telling me what an impact it had on
their communities you know and and how
and suddenly I found myself you know
like in a motel 8 with Kevin Hines who
jumped off the Golden Gate Bridge and
we're going to speak with you know
um high schools of auditoriums of
suicidal kids you know and I'm running
the marathon for Nami and you know and
it's just like I suddenly found that the
that the most poignant thing for me was
the wound the shared wound you know like
when you're when you're suddenly in a
you know with these people who like lost
their kids you know like I mean you know
and they're asking you about why they
committed suicide and you're trying you
know like when you're in those kind of
situations to me
um it was it was the it was the wound
the common wound that we that we share
with a lot of the people uh who who
actually saw the film and but for me the
the biggest it was it was a little
Bittersweet for me
seeing when the van Gogh exhibits came
out because the van Gogh exhibits came
out I was like oh yeah everyone's gonna
be able to see Van Gogh you know
everyone's going to see those Stars the
way he saw them and there was nothing
mentioned about his mental illness you
know and I was really I was like this is
the one opportunity we have
to really show
the beauty in this person who no one
appreciated because he was such a weirdo
you know at the time no one would buy
his art and the funny thing was the
difference between him and Gogan you
know Gauguin was this really charismatic
Charming guy who like you know wanted to
be wild he wanted what Vince Van Gogh
had and he would get so annoyed at him
be like well you can't make things in
such quick Strokes You Know You Gotta
you know put the fine no one saw the
beauty they had and he had a quote that
really moved me which was who am I in
the eyes of most you know what am I in
the eyes of most an eccentric someone
who has no position in society and will
never have all right even if that were
absolutely absolutely true I would like
to one day show by my work with such a
nobody has in his heart
but he still never got to show it
because even when he's hanging in the
Pinnacle of prestige and the MoMA
everyone's gonna leave and they're going
to see some blood guy with bloodshot
eyes homeless on the street they're not
going to know that the same magic is
happening in those eyes
beautiful
[Applause]
and Brittany you've certainly used your
platform and decided to turn it into
something that you want to make an
impact on tell us about what you're
hearing and what comes to you about why
it's important for people to speak out
um I guess it's important to speak out
because I think everyone has a platform
in some way
um I think it's just a matter of what
kind of you know job you do but everyone
has mental health and everyone has a
story to share and I really find for me
the thing that has helped me the most or
that I've found the most valuable is
that shared connection that shared
understanding that we are more alike
than different and mental health is the
great equalizer in that I think that it
doesn't depression anxiety Eating
Disorders bipolar anything doesn't
matter where you came from or what you
look like or what job you have this is a
part of all of our DNA and and so when I
I think as like people who make movies
it's important for us because we do get
and and we're so blessed to do this we
have the opportunity to to share this
story in whatever capacity we can
whether it be writing a movie about it
or just going on social media and
talking about it I think that that's the
connective tissue that is so important
for someone to see themselves
there's this great Julianne Moore quote
where she says you don't go to the
movies to see a character you go to the
movies to see yourself
and I think that that's what we need to
do with mental health is is knowing that
we're really just all just trying to
find each other and see ourselves in
each other
um and so that's why I think it was
important for me to make a movie about
mental health because I wanted a little
girl like I did when I was a little
looking for a movie and to see herself
yeah and all of you are talking about
the power of communities so I want to
pull Brian into this conversation
because there's a lot around cultural
responsiveness as our experts talked
about what it means to be seen as an
individual you decided to use your
audience and create mindset app I'd love
for you to tell our audience a bit about
what the app does what it means to you
why you wanted to do it and where you
hope it takes people in this industry
yeah
um I think it I think it'll be helpful
to give kind of context on how we even
got there so as you mentioned I started
a company called Dive Studios about four
years ago with my brother who's also a
K-pop artist his name is Eric Nam and at
that time we pretty much just set out to
create the first ever media company that
focused on Kpop content and talk show
formats so having K-pop artists open up
just talk about who they are and I know
there's some stigmas around kind of
K-pop being very sheltered and so we
wanted to kind of peel back the layers
and kind of show them as human beings
and so we've launched that four years
ago and very quickly it really took off
and you know today it's still going
we're doing 60 million unique viewers a
month but very early on into dive
Studios
we were really curious about why I was
doing so well and so we created a
Discord Community which is now about 60
000 members and we started talking with
our community like why are you guys
coming to our shows it's not the highest
quality content it's like shot on like
our iPhones and what we were hearing was
uh people were so thankful to have a
platform where they could hear people
they look up to talk about very human
things you know talk about being bullied
in high school growing up Asian American
dealing with stress anxiety depression
and that's kind of where we're like I
think there's something here for us to
provide more of that value and so we
started talking to more of them like
what if we created a platform that was
fully dedicated to this type of
Storytelling and so we launched mindset
about two and a half years ago and is
essentially a wellness app that's rooted
in storytelling with Community that's
kind of powering it all so you know
today we're close to a million users
we've had the pleasure of working with
some of the biggest K-pop names out
there so 17 Keen to G idle DPR and then
also a lot of artists based in the
states so like Tori Kelly summer Walker
amine black everyone coming on to talk
about their own mental health Journeys
and so I think that's all to say like it
came from a place of need not
necessarily us kind of like you know
playing it out and be like oh we're
going to create this mental health app
but just listening to our audience which
is primarily gen Z and just seeing that
there's a need for this kind of joint
discussion around very important topics
and so that's kind of what has brought
us up till today and we're still going
we're you know we're growing and I think
what's been really great is we've been
doing these events on college campuses
now where we kind of bring together
communities like this invite celebrity
speakers and then kind of have that
mindset experience in person so
congratulations that's awesome
um that's so great but I also want to
say too I think of like I get frustrated
my boss often uses this phrase of what
it's like to build a plane while you're
flying it and I can't help but think
about what this means for us here as a
community and I think it I want to just
highlight a question one of our gold
Rising participants wanted us to ask
which I think is valuable here and this
is for anybody but also our subject
matter experts is are there
accommodations or support systems that
you believe this industry should do
better to implement for individuals with
certain types of disabilities or a
disclosed mental health condition and
how can this audience be better about
advocating for those kind of
accommodations
I think um
you know I think uh especially people
with such public platforms and images it
can be very daunting to I think open up
about mental health issues and so I
think
kind of the first step is really
normalizing these conversations having
events in safe spaces like this to talk
about these things
a lot of the artists we've worked with
they've kind of some have like Julia
Michaels said you know mindset was like
a therapy safe space for her and I think
that's really important but then also
when I talk to some other artists they
don't know where to go you know even my
brother Eric he struggled a lot with
mental health in Korea and one thing
that he's very open about is in that
industry to have a mental health issue
or illness it is a very strong stigma
and even his label his company would
tell him don't go see a therapist
because people will hear about it and
then your image is ruined and so I think
you know that may be an extreme case but
I think really normalizing conversations
in the use of Mental Health Resources
and then also providing those resources
is a crucial element to people in this
industry especially we all know how you
know I think
uh how stressful it is yeah yeah go
ahead so thank you Brian I think that
was excellent I think to unpack a little
bit of that when you talk about
normalizing the conversation it just
means it should be like anything else if
I hurt my finger if I hurt my knee if
I'm if I'm having a day where i'm not
feeling well it should be perfectly
normal to do that now this industry is
extremely powerful at all levels and I
remember cases where when when an actor
would have an issue they would be called
troublemakers or nobody would want him
because they would be unreliable right
so I think that the industry does have a
lot of power to be able to take care of
the talent to take care of their actors
directors writers uh who are human
beings who may have an issue just like
if we had a cold or if I am ended up
being diagnosed with cancer the other
part about normalizing the conversation
is we need to learn the language of
mental Wellness we need to stop saying
that person is schizophrenic right we
don't identify the person with the
illness the illness is something
different we need to be able to say a
person that has been diagnosed
with a schizophrenia right so we need to
separate those things we need to make
sure that the person remains that
individual the human being and not
something that we want to make sure that
we put a label on just so we don't have
to deal with them right and we can set
them apart so that's part of what
normalizing the conversation and what
this industry can do and the other part
is on how you portray so I applaud a lot
of the
actors and directors and writers that do
plays in in movies and and shows the
proper way to describe someone that is
having a mental health condition or a
mental illness because it does make a
difference in Breaking that stigma when
we properly portray the individuals that
are suffering from these conditions
you know I I started 30 years ago in
general hospital I and I st they asked
me if I if they could have the character
be bipolar because I'm bipolar and I
said yes and I've been doing it for 30
years I think the problem is that the
the it's it's such an invisible thing
you don't see anxiety you don't see
depression I've gone into work literally
with anxiety that I was gonna just it
was the worst I was crying in the corner
uh but nobody can see that and then
about a month later I got cut here
and people went like oh my God you're
gonna you know they're gonna cut your
arm off
so
um I think as as people who have mental
illness we have to we have to verbalize
it we have to tell people that what
they're feeling what's going on
otherwise you don't really see that
right
I want to highlight though that that's
really hard to do right I mean so I
think um Lexi you use the word
vulnerability and I think it's important
to talk about what it means to lead with
vulnerability I think it's a leadership
skill that's really undervalued but it's
also really hard to do takes a lot of
Courage I'm wondering if some of you
could just share what it means to share
yourself right and things that our
audience can take away as a comfort
about the risk that they may feel they
would have to take if they say something
right or if they disclose or what that
feels like
uh yeah I'll go on this one I think it's
uh by the way tonight's a great first
step you know just having all of us here
talking about this I didn't know that
this was uh possible that you know we
can have people here you know with the
academy talking about uh mental health
but I think just sharing your story you
know it's gonna create that safe space
for people to be themselves and um you
know I'll talk online about having ADHD
it's something that I knew I had as a
kid but you know being in the um uh
African household it doesn't exist right
so I'm gonna tell my mom and she's like
just keep praying and I'm like I'm
praying to the wrong God because I'm you
know still failing these classes uh and
it was actually a Braves game where um I
watched the Braves game and uh the first
baseman uh Adam labroche made an error
and then uh we lost the game to the
Nationals and he got benched and then
after the game he said he had add and he
struggled with uh this thing and that's
why he had the mental laughter in the
game and I think it was very uh helpful
for me I was in seventh grade in Atlanta
Georgia Washington game and that kind of
gave me the confidence to talk talk
about it and when you talk about you
know your struggles it lets other people
come out and talk about their struggles
it's kind of like the Icebreaker because
before you speak up like people just
kind of quiet and just looking around
but once you say something then
somebody'll say oh I have bipolar I have
depression anxiety and then you can
create that safe space where it's okay
to talk about it uh and also as artists
I feel like we have a and content
creators and actors and musicians we
have a responsibility to not only
ourselves but also to other people to
accurately portray you know mental
conditions when we make our art uh and
when I came here you know two years two
and a half years ago time is flying uh
um and I started my entertainment
company and you know I decided to take
social media to the next level uh I made
it a goal to you know portray these
things accurately so if I'm making a
skit about somebody having mac episode
you have to treat them with Grace and
respect and you have to show that it's
not the worst thing in the world you
know some people enjoy that more than
the depression you know if you have
bipolar you might relate to that so I
think it's important to share and even
my DP who's sitting there in the uh from
Rose is birthday by the way uh he uh
yeah
shout out to uh Thomas
um when I was looking for like a
videographer we had like over like 100
applicants within the first hour and um
my assistant like flagged his
application because after he applied he
had like a a paragraph I don't know if
he remembers where he was talking about
how mental is important to him and I was
like we're gonna hire him and like you
know we still told him that we talked to
other people but I'm like that's the
person I want because he's going to be
authentic and and vulnerable and open to
honest and I think once you create that
safe space especially as men because
when we really talk about those things
it lets other people come out and talk
about it and once we have that in the
industry I think it would release some
of the pressure that um you know
creators have because you know I'm sure
the actors can attest to it if you have
an audition or in a stressful event uh
you know your agents you know they care
about your mental health but it might
not be the main priority like you're
thinking about making strong choices and
showing up on time but you might be
having a panic attack in the car so if
we can start talking about these things
is this going to make it easier for all
of us
yeah and sounds like thank you for being
a first right all of you are first which
is super hard to do can't help but think
of a Naomi Osaka as a professional
tennis player and she got fined for not
wanting to do a media interview because
she was feeling depressed after uh
losing a match
um and decided to take her platform and
make that about mental health and sports
especially for women in sports but that
must have been really hard for her I
would love to hear from others you know
what it feels like for you to lead with
vulnerability I don't know maybe we can
go down here yeah
um
well as an actor
it definitely is a little scary
um I think it's always scary just as
humans like when we're putting ourselves
out there in a way in which we're not
necessarily used to or comfortable
having other people see us
um especially when it comes to
whatever Fields but specifically like if
you're in the drama aspects and like I
was saying getting comfortable about
being vulnerable in front of the screen
but also for me is getting comfortable
about being vulnerable by myself as well
and allowing myself to feel those things
and go through the emotions I think that
especially when I was younger I've been
dealing with anxiety and depression
since I was like eight but I didn't
necessarily know what it was I just
suppressed it and I was not giving
myself the space to allow it and to just
let it be um I thought that you know I
was there was something wrong with me or
that I was doing something wrong and I
would say that it's just now within the
past couple of years that I'm really
allowing myself you know not just on
screen but also with my peers with my
family to be open and to be vulnerable
and to be raw because
when I suppress those feelings it
doesn't feel good and it only um makes
you I feel like especially if you are
looking at yourself in a way it makes
you kind of resent yourself even more
and resent the people around you
um that are kind of able to flow without
you know the fear of judgment or without
um yeah without the fear of judgment and
so it's a hurdle to get over as an
artist and then also just as a person in
general being comfortable with it it's a
journey but I'm glad that I'm in this
space now where I can be vulnerable with
myself
totally
Brittany I don't mean to call you in but
I do recall when we were taking pictures
outside we related because we're both
people who are pretty public facing and
I hate having my picture taken and you
said that too like this the least
favorite part so I'd love for you to
talk about what that feels like for you
to also normalize that right there might
be an expectation that you have to be
okay with all aspects of the stress
attached to the industry and maybe some
advice you could give on how you cope
with those kinds of feelings that you
deal with
yeah sure I mean I think what I've tried
to reframe and I think a lot of my
mental health Journey has been about
reframing my my self-talk
um I can view it in one way or I can
look at it from a different lens and a
different perspective and and see it
another way and so for a long time
I was really nervous and shy and anxious
and sad and why can't I speak in public
and why does my voice shake and
um very self-conscious and now I I
realize that it's a part of my
superpower that I'm a super Feeler and I
feel everything
um and especially when people are
looking at me like now
um and um so you know and I think that's
part of the great thing about being you
know creative and also being a good
friend is being open and vulnerable and
empathetic and so yes taking pictures
and things like that is a part of the
job but now I kind of try to reframe it
in my brain of
but I get to be I don't know creative
and empathetic and look at the
photographer or introduce myself to you
and we have a conversation about this
and we can connect in this way
um and I really think that's been a huge
part of of my my journey that I tried to
encapsulate with my movie I wrote I'm
directed and then also with my charity
is that us sharing our vulnerability
should be seen as a strength and our
stories are strong even if they seem
like they're faltering
um I think that anyone who has a mental
health journey and has any perspective
on it has come a long way and that's how
we get better as we connect on our
vulnerability because we're human and we
all have it in some way
[Applause]
so I'd like to switch a little bit to
talk about what it means to portray with
someone uh portray someone who might
have a mental health condition we had a
great question again from one of our
participants in the gold Rising program
about what it means to accurately or
empathically portray a character
struggling with their mental health
whether that's something that they might
have dealt with personally or not
Maurice you talked about the fact that
you disclosed and it became part of your
role but do you have examples of
instances when you brought something to
character in this way that wasn't
explicitly on the script page right
because I think also like the concept of
writing a role about something that you
don't relate to it's really complicated
right I could never understand what it's
like to be any of you just like you
couldn't understand what it's like to be
me so that's a great question I'm
wondering maybe Maurice we could start
with you about what it meant to play
somebody who also had bipolar
um well the problem with I loved it
early on because I'm a you know I'm a
method actor so I
um I said uh play this bipolar and I'm
bipolar so I'm gonna get right in it
right and the problem was it's been
fantastic for my acting but not good for
my life
so
um I'm struggling even you know I've
been there 30 years doing this guy this
character
and it's it's just like it's painful to
play the those emotions and that depth
of him being bipolar I remember doing a
scene one time and it went too long and
my wife called The Producers you got to
cut this now
and I said no
keep going
and I was in a scene and I heard my mom
and dad talking
in the scene
and I said oh no
and that weekend
I woke up in the middle of the night and
I thought I was having my fourth nervous
breakdown and I was having my first
anxiety attack
but you you know you do you got to make
a living
you know
so is what I do you know what I mean
[Applause]
but I think also you know the fear of
rejection is a big ones another question
that came up with from one of our
participants like that itself is so
stressful what if you get it wrong what
if you you don't do the thing somebody
wants to do and that in itself can cause
emotional distress you know depression
um talk to us about how you combat that
and for our experts too maybe how you've
helped somebody navigate that in an
effective way so our audience can have
some tools they can walk away with too
uh yeah so uh I mean when you talk about
rejection I I think it's important I've
told
um you know my patients back in the day
uh uh on the East Coast when I was
working I would tell them that if
somebody rejects you that's their
assessment of you you know and other
people's opinions if you doesn't really
matter and I think that's very important
to keep in mind especially in this
industry because things are very
subjective and you know when we put a
lot of effort into a project or a video
even myself if I post something and
um with social media you get kind of
spoiled I was talking to someone earlier
where I was saying that if a video
doesn't get a million views sometimes
I'll just kind of pace around the house
like what was wrong with it you know and
yeah
we're spoiled we're spoiled I know um
like it'll be at 300 000 I'm like why
did they get stuck you know but uh we
have to reframe how we see things
um it's embarrassing to even admit it
but uh yeah so I'm always trying to you
know just be comfortable with who I am
and just tell myself that you know my
best is always good enough and as long
as it comes from the heart you should be
you know okay with that because you know
like tonight we're here at you know with
the academy and like that's what you
know there's nothing bigger than that
when it comes to acting but even if you
don't if you don't recognize you're
still the artist you're still somebody
who's worthy of Love attention and
respect so I think it's important to
just create this community where we can
give ourselves credits for just doing
like the doing should be what we're
proud of because if we're outcome based
uh I worry that the more outcome based
you are you're going to put yourself at
risk for depression anxiety and uh you
know poor mental health outcomes so it's
important to keep that in mind yeah
really great points there I saw a purely
G first and then we'll come to you
Maurice so thank you thank you for
disclosing that you have videos with
less than a million
to an audience my cat my cat videos get
like six like so um
one of the important things though is is
we can't do this by ourselves right so
when we disclose about our conditions in
in the environment that we disclose it
in we need to make sure that we can
either
have the supports or we have the ability
to build the supports that we're going
to need you know because if someone
and again it's about
equity
right Equity means
fairness it means that everyone if
someone is on set and they they hurt
their knee there's a team that comes in
and takes care of that knee if someone
is on set and they have a panic attack
or they have an episode of depression we
don't have the people running in to take
care of that right so we need to look at
that Equity now people confuse that with
the quality equality means everybody
gets the same thing but equality only
works if everyone begins at the same
place and everyone has the same
situation which is not the the
the fact
so we need to continue to work on equity
and if we're going to to do this we need
to make sure that we either have the
supports in place or that we have the
ability to build the support so what
does that mean that means that everyone
needs to play a role
right so not only the actor but the
director the producer the writers uh
even the the key grip or or the lights
everybody needs to play a role to be
able to support that individual because
it takes a lot of Courage for someone to
say that in today's environment where we
do judge where we do put a stigma where
we do keep people out because of
something that we may not fully
understand
and the reality is that there's millions
of people that are living with a mental
illness and are having a wonderful
successful life but we need to continue
to support that and then let's not
forget about the Allies because
sometimes you know I often tell people
first we need to find our voice right
you find your voice and you figure out
how it is that you need to describe
something or tell someone what it is
that you're thinking but then once we
find our boys is Our obligation to use
our voice because we may be the only
ones that can be there for somebody
right so the allies of of those people
we surround ourselves with they need to
also be able to help us until we're able
to stand up and we're able to speak up
for ourselves
thank you
let me see we're gonna yeah I just want
to add on to what was said I mean one
thing it's taken me about 58 years to
not care what people think
and in the last two years
I haven't I've been working on it a lot
and it you can do it and when you don't
care what people think
you fly
and so I wish I had learned that when I
was young man
I think it would have been incredible
but anyway it's it's very important to
you know to do that and try to try to
have that
Paul you've had varying experiences you
were sharing a bit what supports have
worked for you you know what do you
think the audience could hear too about
pushing themselves through something
that might be helpful for them to seek
out to
I think having a different relationship
with suffering is something that you
have to do if you're bipolar if you're
bipolar like him and me like I'm bipolar
one
you can't avoid suffering you have to
have a you have to embrace it you have
to have a different kind of relationship
with suffering and it can go for as far
as physical pain
you know like um you have to do things
that other people don't have to do you
know like I you know you've I fast I've
gone eight days without food one time
you know I've got I've I've you know
I've I do cold showers I I I I I I I you
know do keto I do light box I do intense
exercise you know just stuff that other
people don't have to do you have to do
and you just have to just face it and
just Embrace pain the other thing is to
embrace suffering emotional suffering
you can't avoid suffering if you're
bipolar one of the one of the one of the
most beautiful characters is for me is
Dionysus you know cause diani sees you
know one of the first books they gave us
when we were the dramatic writing
program was Aristotle's Poetics and what
people were were always like shocked
about was the way Aristotle described
tragedy as being the most ecstatic art
form and the highest art form and the
highest feeling of spiritual
enlightenment came from witnessing these
tragedies and they would bring out a
statue of Dionysus because Dionysus is
the god of Madness he's the god of
Madness and he's the god of tragedy but
they would bring out the statue of
dionyses on the day of the Greek plays
when they would because he represented
embracing suffering and bringing Beauty
to it through ART and he was able to you
know in his Madness they would say he
you know the spirit of Dionysus can can
turn that suffering into wine you know
and beauty and and that's the kind of
relationship you have to have to pain
and suffering whether if you're bipolar
that's just all there is to it
yeah and there's been some comments too
about what it means to like make it
unique for you right and what that feels
like and Brian like you alluded to as
well the impact you're having in the
Asian American community and in the
K-pop industry I can't imagine what that
feels like too to also carry a weight on
your shoulders about being the person
facilitating those messages if you can
talk about what that's felt like for you
yeah I think you know for us we're I
think to start like when we talked to
our community or even publicly like
we're very upfront about you know these
are stories that we're not working with
public figures to say that they have the
solutions to solving your mental health
issues but simply leading with
storytelling and I think you know when
we first started out people said that we
were crazy like mental health K-pop like
there's just no way that ever happens
um but I think what we saw is that you
get one person to take that first step
to kind of be the first one on the
platform to show that we can share these
stories in a way that's you know that's
safe that's non-triggering but also
helpful to their fans and I think one by
one we started working with more and
more artists and I think that has been
the biggest pressure of continuously
doing right by the talent and making
sure that their stories are delivered in
a way that uh that they're happy with
and so we're we're very upfront that
they have 100 creative control we've had
some people that have recorded 13
episodes and then last minute they're
like I just I'm not ready to release
this and so we just haven't released it
so that I think for us it's always
leading with the the town first approach
and I think for us like you know
to your question of like what's the
weight bin I think honestly it's really
on all the people working with I'm just
lucky to be able to kind of help
facilitate it but
um yeah I think it's it's all the
Applause and kind of just shout out to
them for even being the ones that share
their stories
yeah and the wait is there right I mean
if if we didn't feel we I always say if
it doesn't feel uncomfortable you're not
doing it right but also like if you
don't feel weight about these things
then we're devaluing what our emotions
are and what they feel like
um and I'm hopeful the two of you on the
end too could maybe tell us like what's
worked for you and if you have some
examples that could be helpful for our
audience
what has worked for me
um when it comes to
moments of um you know not necessarily
feeling enough
um a big thing that my mom
um like used to tell me when I was
younger because I've experienced panic
panic attacks for quite a while so she
um she used to
um tell me basically in those moments of
you know self-doubt to look myself in
the mirror every day and tell myself I
love you
um and if you you know if you do that
consistently every at least once a day
that you know it only reinforces in
yourself how you're going to allow other
people to treat you how you treat other
people and how you treat yourself and so
by doing that in the moments where I
don't necessarily feel like I know
what's going on or I feel like I'm you
know losing my mind I kind of just
remind myself that I am enough and that
I do matter things like also meditation
are just so big for me I think that it's
so easy especially with what we do to
just get caught up in everything
especially social media to compare we
were talking about rejection as well to
take it to heart and to feel as though
you know it's a personal issue but in my
opinion rejection is protection and so
if you continue to instill that in
yourself and just give yourself at least
like 15 to 20 minutes a day just pure
Solitude and allowing yourself to be and
sit with your thoughts and your emotions
that definitely has helped me get a get
through
um and jump over the hurdles that I've
experienced when it comes to Mental
Health
[Applause]
can you repeat the question of what it
what which questions what's worked for
you oh what's worked yeah in general
yeah oh okay
um oh gosh how much time do we have
um I I mean I think I think you know I
started on my mental health journey I
guess when I was when I was 12 years old
and I I read
um an article in a magazine about a girl
who had was going through what I was
going through and it sort of you know
connected me to that
um I think what's really important for
me is having a toolbox of things because
like we were saying not everyone has
access to therapy not everybody also
wants to go to therapy and not
definitely can't afford to talk to a
therapist every single day I know I
can't and so um or nor do I want to
sorry no offense
um and um uh so I think that there's a
lot of different things that I I think
really work in order to have a toolbox
of sorts of things that you can pull
from when you just know that oh you're
getting in that place again and maybe it
a walk outside a podcast a
um a bath or something that you're doing
for yourself to to disconnect from the
fact that I think that there's sometimes
your your mental health mind that kind
of is this ticker tape hamster wheel and
then also the loving adult voice in your
head that says no no just listen to a
nice song and reframe this and take a
moment to understand that like maybe you
don't have all the answers and you might
need to you know take a second and like
you said press pause
um I think that's been really helpful
but knowing how big your toolbox is and
where it is I think it's been really
impactful
um and and stuffing it with a bunch of
stuff
stuffing it with a bunch of stuff you
can add something real quick I I just
thought it was
um recently uh as of late I've been
struggling with boundaries you know and
um during the pandemic I went to therapy
for the first time and then my therapist
kind of connected it to you know not
being uh given choices as a child so I
couldn't be assertive so it was harder
as an adult and um the thing with
boundaries is you know it's hard to
enforce them with the people that you
love because there's a chance that you
could lose them so
um as I've been struggling with this uh
you know my brothers live with me now
here in LA and like I'll explain things
to him and uh what that does for me it
helps give me uh a why to my suffering
and we're talking about suffering
earlier and it's something that it's
it's not gonna Escape any of us in life
we're going to have to suffer in some
capacity and I think it's important to
give your suffering a why and understand
that all right I'm suffering but there's
there's gonna be something that comes
out of this that's productive for me
because if you can't give your suffering
a why then you'll feel like you're just
suffering endlessly and I believe that
could lead to hopelessness and
helplessness so when you realize that
okay I'm struggling with this but what
kind of lesson can I extract from it and
not only help myself and help out other
people it kind of helps y'all in the
moment and also makes you feel better
because you're helping out other people
foreign
well I'd just like to take an
opportunity to do something really quick
um before we close unfortunately but it
is that I'd like each of you to think
about one thing you wish you had known
towards your mental health when you
started in your career and even for the
folks who are maybe not actors but
that's an important lesson for everybody
so we're going to go down the row we'll
start here with you what's one thing you
wish you had known when you started that
you know now I think I I already I think
I already said it you know if I had
worked on not caring what people think
and also chipping away at my ego which
got me in big trouble for many many
years you got to get rid of that if I
had known that earlier too and how to do
it it would have made my life a lot
easier awesome
Paul
um I reflect a lot what he says about
the ego you know because um I think it's
a one of the things that I when I made
touch with fire I was like so thinking
oh I'm gonna make money off of this I'm
just gonna blow up you know and none of
that happened and suddenly like 12
mental health organizations reach out
and I'm like in a motel with Kevin Hines
I'm like this is heaven you know and I'm
like what is this is what it's about I
wish I had known the purpose of of why
we make stories when I set out to do it
you know because then I I would have
appreciated it all the more
you know it's important to remember that
thank you
I I would say I'm not alone
I'm not alone and it's okay whatever I'm
going through whatever feeling I have
it's okay
I'm not alone and it's okay to ask for
help
right
um
I'd say I wish I learned how to kind of
label my emotions and kind of what I was
going through at a younger age I think
uh growing up in a kind of Korean Asian
American household like my parents
didn't know any of these terms anxiety
depression any of that and I think I
went through a lot of that High School
and if I had kind of known that's what I
was going through I think I would have
been able to embrace it and then kind of
find Solutions earlier so I think being
able to label kind of what you're going
through and then to Bernie's point about
reframing kind of whatever it is you're
going through I think for myself and a
lot of people I talk to imposter
syndrome is something that a lot of
people struggle with and I think for me
you know I still feel it even on this
stage and I think it's reframing as like
you know it's it's a sign that you're
pushing your boundaries they're out of
your comfort limit and I think that's
really helped me kind of get through
those moments where it's really at its
peak yeah
uh for me I wish I would have um really
understood the importance of kindness
you know uh first of all to myself
because I really pushed myself hard out
and that's how I've been my whole life
and uh you know even in High School
playing football like I loved like that
aggressive nature of like just pushing
yourself to exhaustion so I think
um I wish I would have known the
importance of being kind uh uh and not
only to myself but just to other people
you know because everybody's going
through something uh whether they have a
condition or not and
um just by you reaching out and you know
maybe give them like a big Drew
Barrymore hug you know it could just
make them feel like they're loved so um
kindness is uh way more important than
uh we give it credit thank you
um I would have to say that I would tell
my younger self to
embrace who I am because those things
that I might dislike or try to change
are actually my superpowers and they are
the things that I've you know as a kid I
was to this and not enough this and all
these things but that's what made me
really strong and empathetic and
creative and so I would go back and and
really lean into those things because
you are who you are when everyone else
is taken
um I would say number one that it's okay
to not be okay
um especially when I was younger and I
first started experiencing all these
feelings and emotions like I said it
earlier like I thought that I was
crazier that there was something wrong
with me
um but just being able to give myself
the space to just be and understand that
it's okay
um and to bask in the moment even if
it's just like 15 minutes of you know
crying and of having a panic attack just
allowing myself to sit in that space
um and then I would also say when it
comes to career is that comparison is
the biggest thief of Joy
um I still find myself doing it
sometimes I think that as human beings
like it's just like a natural thing
where if we go on social media if we go
somewhere like we're gonna compare
um but for when it comes to
um career specifically think that it's
important that you know you're not like
in a race you're the only person that
you're competing with yourself in a
sense is you
um and as long as you're making yourself
proud at the end of okay that's all that
matters
thank you all I'm gonna do something off
the cuff can everybody just take one big
deep breath in
and out together I really want to thank
our panelists and our experts for being
so vulnerable and so candid so smart
intelligent powerful amazing all these
things
um you all embodied what leading what
vulnerability really means today I can't
stress this enough it's a really
undervalued skill it's something I wish
we all could have the courage to do and
I really thank you for being champions
of mental health makes my job a lot
easier when we have people like you
choosing to do what you did today so
thank you so much we get a big round of
applause for our panelists
[Applause]
that concludes our panel for the evening
so thank you all so much I will hand it
over to closing to go through the
logistics of how we end but thank you